Narrator: A city in China wants to launch
an artificial moon into
orbit by 2020 as a way
to reduce energy needs
by replacing street light
with artificial moonlight.
Regardless of whether or not they succeed,
their ambitious idea
really made us wonder.
What would happen if Earth had two moons?
Well, it wouldn't be pretty.
Imagine the moon's identical
twin comes hurtling by
and is trapped by Earth's gravity.
As it settles into orbit
halfway between Earth
and our original moon, it
yanks violently at the oceans.
In the real world, this
is how our original moon
helps generate tides.
So, the second moon
would amplify the effect
causing peak tides that
would be six times higher,
eroding shorelines and flooding many
of our world's greatest
cities including New York,
Singapore, and London, gone.
But not all destruction
would happen on Earth.
The combined pull of the
planet and the original moon
would also yank on the second moon.
The second moon would be
caught in a tug of war
between earth and the original moon.
The gravitational pull back
and forth from both ends
would warp the second moon's surface
triggering tremendous
volcanic activity flooding
the second moon's surface
with red hot rivers of lava
just like hundreds of the
volcanoes you see today
on Jupiter's hellish moon, Io.
But even that's not the
end of the spectacle.
Right now, our current moon
is spiraling away from Earth
at 3.8 centimeters a year.
That's about how fast
your fingernails grow.
At the same time, it pulls on the Earth
slowing down the planet's
rotation which is actually
lengthening our days by around one second
every 40, 000 years.
It may not sound like much,
but with two moons in place,
it would accelerate
this process even more.
Millions of years from now,
the day will have grown by 16%,
lasting longer than 28 hours.
Now a little extra time in
the day may sound pretty nice,
but here's the problem,
the extra moon would drift
towards the current moon
and that's where the real danger comes in.
After millions of years,
the two moons would collide.
The impact would be so massive,
it would rip the very
core of the moons apart.
Lava would erupt from their center
like a runny egg in space
casting a vivid, red light
in the sky on Earth.
Meanwhile, debris would go
hurtling in all directions
where some of it would
inevitably strike Earth
forming massive craters miles wide.
It would be an apocalypse
for all life on Earth.
And what didn't hit the planet
would instead be trapped
by Earth's gravity
forming a ring of debris
around the equator similar
to the rings around Saturn.
But not for long.
Within just a few years, those
chunks would clump together
forming one, large, single body.
Perhaps any life that survived
will call it the moon,
or maybe something even better.